brian eisenberg welcome to always be
testing the power of small incremental
continuous improvement to improve the
quality of your marketing
for the last almost 12 years i've been
focused on helping companies improve
their marketing and improve their
conversion rates
and it comes to no surprise to me in
today's marketplace that a lot of things
that are people are getting excited
about and getting focused on are still
not the very things that i've been
preaching for the last decade
and so what i wanted to share with you
today was a little bit of a story
that started just about
10 years ago or so
when we're working with one of our very
first uh paying customers his name was
jason cement he was the ceo of
magmal.com
and uh he was uh trying to improve his
business and and get more sales and he
was talking to an incubator and trying
to raise money uh because a competitor
of his e-news uh had just finished
raising close to 100 million dollars in
funding uh of course to get lots of
people to subscribe to magazines from
their website
and the one thing for sure is back then
both websites really weren't very good
um but at the end of the day you know if
you had to compare no funds to 100
million dollars you'd assume that the
site with 100 million dollars would be
the huge success of course you know they
can invest in all kinds of marketing
efforts all kinds of innovative ideas
and spend more on driving traffic than
the smaller site with no funding
well we work with jason um and started
making some small changes to his website
added a unique value proposition cleaned
up the navigation
slowly started making changes to the
color scheme eventually a couple years
later we redesigned the website and you
can see it looks a lot more professional
back then um you know we talked about
all the great benefits that he has to
help make people dive right into some of
the key magazines that were uh the main
purchases
and um we took his conversion rate from
a
1.11
conversion rate so a little over one
percent of the people came purchasing
from him to a 4.93
conversion rate so almost a five times
impact on his conversion rate
where at the very same time as this
success that jason was achieving
uh e news unfortunately had to regret
people that the enewswood.com website
had been closed
the 100 million dollars of course and
all the great innovation and great
marketing
couldn't make people
buy from them
uh and in the end jason's still in
business today and and the main reason
is because he focused on this concept of
continuous improvement he just said look
i can keep improving experience for my
customers improve my conversion rate
make my traffic more profitable and
that my dollars stretch further and of
course that was a huge success for him
now this is not a new concept in fact w
edward deming who sent by the u.s
government after world war ii to japan
to help their economy prosper
taught them the concept of total quality
management of quality control and
improving the experience um that people
had with the their manufacturing in fact
deming's whole premise was about
improving the quality will reduce your
expenses and improve the quality of your
experience your workers and
gaining market share and of course
that's exactly what we're trying to do
and it's the same kind of concept that
we'll be talking about today that will
help your marketing and your business
improve by focusing in on the right
aspects